i had not read any of the game of
thrones books and i had
kind of a uh a thing where i said to
myself you know
probably don't want to read these things
because you know i tried to read robert
jordan
and i couldn't read any of those books
and uh
so i thought probably these are just
terrible
stephen king hates the wheel of time
apparently
we can't have it all you know we were
getting greedy
we were getting i don't know where i'm
going with that i watched this
conversation between george rr martin
and stephen king
a long time ago and you know what this
clip always uh
stuck with me this video is going to be
a kind of um
exploration of what exactly this comment
means and my own speculation about what
it means because
it caused me a lot more distress than i
would like to admit why because i feel
like all of my
my favorite writers need to like each
other that's weird
i'm currently reading both of these
writers most
popular fantasy series the dark tower
right and
um the other the
that one why does stephen king hate the
wheel of time
point one let's look at the first book
of both of these series
first book of the wheel of time is a
very
grounded realistic take on a kind of
traditional
fantasy epic so we have that and then
let's look at the first book of the dark
tower series
i don't know what tradition it's coming
from except it's a mashup of western
sergio leone science fiction acid trip
book one may be a a western acid trip
but book 2 is like an 80s james cameron
action flick book 3 is a talking train
these are
really totally different series point
number two
i don't want to speculate too much about
this because it is
just speculation but i think there is a
type of
battle between writers especially since
stephen king was writing the dark tower
series throughout the 90s
well throughout the 80s the 90s and the
early 2000s i think stephen king's
just standalone horror novels probably
sold
better but his his dark tower books from
my understanding
didn't reach the kind of popularity that
uh
the wheel of time did and again this is
just speculation
who knows maybe stephen king had a piece
of uh
crappy moldy bread before he picked up
with the eye of the world and was like
oh
man my stomach hurts and i don't i'm
just not vibing with these characters
i'm gonna put it down
and never read it again that could be
the case who knows now point number
three and the final point from what i
understand about
robert jordan's writing process is that
he was a serious plotter and planned out
each book
had notes substantial notes especially
for brandon sanderson when he
took over this at the end of the series
i think that's just fundamentally
different to how a writer like stephen
king or george rr martin crafts a story
just flying through seeing what happens
you get that sense
from the dark tower series it can go
here it can go there it can go
literally anywhere you wouldn't see
fourth wall breaks
in the wheel of time that's what i'm
trying to say in conclusion while
stephen king's comments were
kind of like uh huh i wonder why he
hates
the wheel of time now that i think about
it more it
it does make a lot of sense they do seem
like very different writers in terms of
their approach to storytelling
their interests and their personal takes
on fantasy
you know because these are two writers
who really put
two massive epics out one
is super self-referential
unplanned and one is meticulously
planned uh very self-contained it's it's
just an interesting
case study you know in a lot of ways
between how to how-to writers
uh in their prime approached the
idea of like rewriting tolkien writing
the
epic fantasy uh for their time what do
you all think huh
is it just is it just me do i think am i
the only kind of person who thinks this
is interesting
i've been i've been reading too much of
the dark tower in the wheel of time
honestly because this is starting to
and naturally as a person who thinks in
binaries
i want to side with one over the other
but no i can't do that
i can't do that it's wrong i like them
both
for very different reasons thanks for
[Music]
watching